I got the point from Erin welcome to I
seem fun the diary of jen kirkman
podcast episode 156 coming to you live
from the all things comedy studio in
Hollywood California this is available
as a live stream right now if you're
watching it it will be archived later so
you can look at it now let me explain
something before all you haters get on
my [ __ ] house I'm in doing this
podcast for three years it has a great
fan base it is a podcast you're supposed
to listen to this live stream is not a
television show does not meant to be
visually stimulating except me and my
fantastic shirt it is you are watching
someone record something that is meant
to be listened to so don't complain a
nicki boring of course it's boring it's
a podcast but if you're watching it it's
to just get a sense of what it looks
like when I talk and you get in it so
feel self-conscious I put my sunglasses
on so this week I thought it would be
fun so my podcasts I seem fun is a diary
it is me talking about what happened in
my life and if we talk about what's
going on in the world every week great
there's many private jokes there's many
little things as you know if you're
dropping in for the first time this is a
well-established world so get in it
don't hate I seem fun business up top
everybody my comedy special I'm gonna
die alone and I feel fine which is
streaming worldwide and Netflix is also
available wherever albums are sold
digitally you can listen to it for 999 I
seem fun podcast is available on google
play soundcloud you can subscribe on
itunes give it five stars and write in
the review section I don't have time to
listen to podcast that's a private joke
for the show go to our Facebook there's
a new web address for the facebook
account of i seem fun at all [ __ ] if i
can find it it's um FB dot me /i seem
fun podcast I don't know why they
changed on me they [ __ ] dit twitter at
I seem fun podcast these are ways to get
in touch with me I'll
when you guys commune on the facebook
fan page join my email list no not join
send me an email at I seem fun at gmail
com you can tell me things that you find
fun that other people don't or things
that other people find fun that confuse
you i think i just said the same thing
twice you can also send me questions or
things you want me to read on air again
as I said I'm part of the All Things
comedy network go to all things comedy
calm and look at the other or listen to
the other awesome podcast and December
third los angeles i will be at the
hollywood improv 8pm for the jen kirkman
4th annual dysfunctional Christmas show
I would hurry up and get tickets because
we just had a giant party of I think 75
people who are having an office party
coming to that show so that took a
significant bite out of tickets don't
wait its twenty bucks for twenty bucks
you get a night full of great comics
talking about dark and stupid family
stories me and the part of the donation
goes to the LA Food Bank and if you want
to be extra charitable bring child's
pajamas new and a book children's book
for the pajama program and/or you hope
to bring a pajama and a book and you can
donate it in the box there and i will
send it to a great program called the
pajama program so go to jen kirkman calm
click on tour dates tickets are
available hollywood improv december
third 8pm it's a [ __ ] great show and
so you i seem fun errs i really need you
to come out and bring the charitable
gift because i think regular people that
just buy tickets they're not going to
read that they should bring pajamas in a
book and or a book alright great so
that's the business up top I thought
today would be a good day well my
podcast comes out every Tuesday night at
nine and I had to record one anyway and
I thought maybe it'd be good to do one
during the election because people might
be nervous as [ __ ] and they want to get
their mind off it and listen to or watch
something that isn't about the election
so I will not be talking about the
election today as we know it I might
mention something about women getting
the right to vote in an interesting fact
about that but I have nothing to say
we're not
uh giving you live updates on any states
or what's happening I have no
information I'm in a bubble tonight
after this podcast I'm going home I'm
putting up my Christmas tree it's not a
it's a fake tree so it's not going to
catch on fire in three weeks and I
bought it from this website called
balsam hill and they try to make it look
as real as possible and they send you
when they send it you the tree these
gardening gloves to put on when you put
the tree together and then spread out
the branches and I was like well that's
adorable they're trying to make it
authentic someone's drummond do you
think it'll be picked up on the pod okay
I'm fine with it so um and then I
started assembling the tree and I cut my
hands all up and so when I go finish the
rest tonight I'll put on my son little
gloves but decorate it and the way I
looked at I'm a Hillary supporter oh my
god she's a criminal and so the way I
look at it is again if she wins I'll
have a beautiful thing to look at it's
feminist Christmas or if not Trump wins
everything goes in the toilet and at
least I can just take a klonopin and
stare at my Christmas tree so that's all
I'll say about the election now how
listen I'm sorry to get so lady heavy at
the beginning but I saw a friend of mine
tweet um you know she said when she was
growing up she's in a band women were
told they couldn't play bass and so she
said this tonight is big for me first
woman president and so I took a cue from
her and I put on Twitter this true story
um I said when I was in grade school a
teacher told the boys when I was taking
typing I can't find the tweet that's why
I'm saying it unless where the [ __ ]
tweet I said um when I was in sixth
grade the male typing teacher told the
boys they didn't have to pass class
because they would have girls
secretaries that was a real thing this
is before computers wait word processors
and typing was really seen as a gender
specific thing you know men at this
point now of course whether you're an
executive or not men
and women type I think fairly equally
I'm sure there's statistics and
everyone's going to yell at me but you
know we were using our iphones our
blackberries men use their laptop to
send emails or look up porn or whatever
and so people are typing back then it
was really kind of a female thing your
secretary you type and this was only in
1986 I mean it wasn't the 1800s and so
some guy on Twitter wrote unless you're
way older than you look he was an
anachronism even then no he wasn't
because i had a science teacher who told
me i should just get pregnant and give
up my dream of being an actor i had a
gym teacher who molested one of the
girls and she was so afraid to talk
about it she didn't report him we had
the teachers were monsters some of the
male teachers i would say about thirty
percent of them said sexist things was
even all the way into college and so i
wrote back to this guy no he wasn't it
was 1986 and i heard [ __ ] like that well
into the 90s from teachers don't tell
women their experience then he writes
back I was in grade school a decade
before that and he wouldn't have gotten
away with that and i wrote you can't be
sure that you were aware of every
instance of sexism in your childhood and
cuz you didn't hear about it that it
didn't happen like I just I just I wish
if Hillary getting elected tonight I had
no of course here I'm talking about the
election if it could wash away one thing
it would be this men telling women
they're experienced I know it seems
innocent I'm just tweeting and you're
like he's giving his opinion but why is
he giving an opinion on my fact why
would you give an opinion on someone's
truth that's what I'm understand no he's
just giving an opinion just let's have
an opinion about there's no opinion
about what happened to me but one of the
instances that happened to me you don't
need to give your opinion if a black
person tweeted Oh 20 years ago my
teacher told me that you know I looked
like a thug you wouldn't tweet them that
wouldn't have that that you know that
was a bad teacher that's not what it's
like yes it is yes it is it is so men
can be who are looking to exonerate them
says of the word exonerate whatever the
word is they're looking they're taking
everything so personally said why why do
you have to explain to me that that guy
was like one in a million like that
never happens that's the reason I
hold it if it was just one dude I would
never even mention it cuz I would have
forgotten about it it was but one of the
many experiences what don't we get about
that by now on Twitter what don't we get
about that by now it's just one time a
woman got Kat calm it's every 10 minutes
of every goddamn [ __ ] day so i I just
I wish Hilary being elected which is
make men magically get it but the thing
that's empowering me is I give less of a
[ __ ] what dudes think like I used to
just block or be like oh I don't know
and now I'm like [ __ ] you I didn't want
you as a fan you're too dumb like when
they be like I was just saying this
block goodbye because just saying it is
not cutting it anymore you don't know
basic things about other people in this
country who don't have it as easy as you
you don't know basic things you don't
tell someone that someone who did
something to them is just one person who
really is in the minority you're not
correct you literally can't be correct
about a place you weren't in a town you
don't even know where I grew up you
don't know what you know nothing you
know nothing god I'm fire it up today
fired up and now tell you one other
thing that happened to me on Twitter
yesterday maybe the trans people came
after me and now the Liberals come after
me listen you little narcissist
Millennials we could get on your sansa
unless you're trans don't come after me
about trans people so this non trans
woman started to tell me what's up
yesterday I tweeted this and that will
then we'll stop talking about the
election I was watching a speech Hillary
may lessen her voice sounded
touch-and-go as regular listeners my
podcast you will be all too well
acquainted with my vocal-cord issues as
a public speaker there's something very
depressing about not having total vocal
control if you try to go I don't know
and instead comes out your cords are
inflamed if your cords are inflamed it
means every time you speak you are doing
them more damaged and the more inflamed
they get the less of a voice you have
until
you lose it completely so hearing Hilary
talk at the top of her voice not doing
proper breath control being like well
dough that's Philadelphia I tweeted hey
girl save your voice you don't want
vocal fry tomorrow when you're talking
about how you smash the glass ceiling
well what didn't you know it first of
all within one minute a dude wrote to me
you never tweet about her policies only
about how much you hate men never said
that it's not sexist to vote for someone
who's going to be the first woman
president does anyone understand that
it's not an act against men is the most
qualified person and I'm a Democrat
secondly I'm psyched she's a woman
because i think is important for culture
to have every kind of person eventually
serve as the president so i was excited
god forbid it doesn't mean i want to cut
everyone's dick off okay so but then
three minutes later and we get the other
side of it too liberal for their own
good looking for things on the internet
this girl wrote to me so before i tell
you what this girl tweeted let's take
apart what I tweeted I used the term
vocal fry and I didn't mean to use that
term us and Hillary we don't have vocal
fry when you're speaking tomorrow night
would I have what she has what people
with damaged vocal cords have is not
quite vocal fry vocal fry is when you
lazily let the end of your sentence drop
to this and you sound kind of gravely
there's a whole thing going on in this
world in the last couple years about
vocal fry it's a thing you know like
Paris Hilton talks like that I know
Howard Stern did a big thing on this on
his show a lot of young girls talk like
that and they talk sort of like a sudden
I got onto the bulk up ah and it's a
weird trend member valliegrl speaking
80s like oh my god everyone started
talking like that so vocal fries sort of
the new trend in talking and I think the
reason well the reason my vocal coach
wouldn't like it is because it does
cause damage to your chords eventually
that's secondly people don't like it
because it sounds annoying but third I
guess the new thing is so the thing that
used to be a couple years ago was like
all these women are talking and vocal
fry it's bad
it sounds annoying and why are they
doing it to me it comes off as a sort of
insecurity if you speak in a way that
sounds like how everyone else is
speaking if there's a trend in
vocalization to me it sounds insecure
but I guess the new thing and I'm a
FEMINIST and I don't agree with this is
that stop telling women not to have
vocal fry because you're saying that
women should only have high pitched
voices and I didn't say that my voice is
low low low but you need to keep it
clear clear clear so I was not saying
that then I guess there's a thing where
people transitioning there's a big
debate should you have a woman's voice
if you you know quote woman's voice if
you're transitioning into a woman oh if
you're going through the transition your
voice can get raspy from learning to
talk a different way and not getting it
at first or you choose to have it that
way or whatever that's not what i was
talking about I'm talking about a non
trans woman who is not trying to speak
in vocal fry who has a perfectly good
not to female not too masculine voice
who is going to lose it from improper
vocal technique and she's a public
speaker and I was just thinking how you
know if she's the first female president
and all it'd be nice if she had a
[ __ ] voice tonight I was worried
about her losing her voice completely so
this girl wrote again a girl who is not
trans wrote to me well Jen and explained
the whole vocal fry thing to me that I
just explained to you as if I to [ __ ]
know it like you write one thing in
these kids think you're stupid it's like
honey I'm old enough to be your mother I
know a thing or two but where I have the
maturity you don't as I don't [ __ ]
type it out on the internet all day to
people you can know things and shut the
[ __ ] up about it unless asked and so I
wrote sorry I use the word vocal fry
have 140 characters i meant to say hope
she doesn't lose her voice and then the
girl wrote know that did you read what i
read it's still important to learn [ __ ]
you i know it already
so then someone trans wrote I'm transits
didn't offend me you said someone didn't
to lose their voice and then in that way
that you do when you're a desperate to
be correct I'm like that's right one
trans person agree with me and so the
yet so then someone else wrote about the
girl that wrote you know don't make fun
of trans people which I wasn't doing
this other woman wrote but Jen it's
important to hear all points of view and
I think that you should take in what she
said okay I have to take in what she
said because I already know what she
said she's willfully misunderstanding
what I tweeted I just want the president
whether it's a man a woman a dog or a
cat the president presidential candidate
that I support I don't them to lose
their voice before their big speech [ __ ]
yourself if you read anything more to
its complete narcissism especially I
could understand if you were the group
if a transperson was just all day long
now [ __ ] hatred that comes at her for
being trans and that in the voice issues
and and that you read something really
quick and you're like no I'm sick of
people and you tweet that that's fine
but someone who's not who's just like
social justice warrior in for everyone
else it's narcissism it's [ __ ]
narcissism you want to be heard so badly
you want to feel important so badly it
is not about standing up for the little
guy it just [ __ ] isn't because if you
had that kind of empathy you have that
kind of empathy towards me that's it
period end of story I don't mean I'm the
little guy but I mean you would read
something and not assume the worst of
someone so I know I'm fired up today
yelling at the camera I'm not normally
this Howard Beale but this is how I feel
so
sorry I'm checking Twitter while I just
listen someone said I had CNN on and was
feeling the need for xanax switched to
the Jen Kirkman I seem fun live stream
instead shoutout to Rochelle um perfect
sorry I just tweeted something really
shitty to that guy he wrote back the guy
that wrote about the typing teacher he
wrote changes slow i guess and probably
spotty and lurching and i wrote back
yeah no [ __ ] women have known this
forever thanks for catching up uh I'm
something the moon not in the mood we're
not gonna take it no isn't that Trump
song it was at the beginning um okay so
here's what I wanted to talk about all
right listen was just [ __ ] I can't
not think about stuff going on in
relation to the election air and I can't
you forgive me Erin doesn't care he's is
he understands how he's dealing with you
well I thought I would be I was cool
that everyone's going to susan b anthony
is grave and um putting the i voted
sticker on it i'm actually can't believe
no one has stopped that because it's
technically defacing public property
because an oscar wilde's grave in france
no big deal you guys don't have to go
there if you don't want to people would
kiss it with lipstick marks i I was one
of them and then I went back to it a
couple years later and they put a giant
fence around it so you can't uh I feel
like Oscar wold will love them but I
don't know susan b anthony i mean she
loved the gesture so then you know a lot
of articles are going around and i think
it's very important to note that the
women's suffragette movement wasn't
totally inclusive of african-american
women in this sense that now here's
where I get tripped up because a lot of
people are like susan b anthony is great
if you like white feminism it's like I
don't know if susan b anthony herself
was only appealing to white women um
from what i have read frederick douglass
worked with a bunch of women black and
white to help keep women's rights moving
along i do know that history gets
whitewashed but i don't know if we can
blame susan b anthony for that i didn't
maybe that's not what people are saying
maybe people are saying I identify more
with other people so you know women got
the right to vote in nineteen twenty
black and white women but it wasn't
until nineteen sixty-five that we had
the oh god what the hell is the name of
it is the voting voting uh voting oh
geez Louise I can't think of the name of
the Voting Rights Act the Voting Rights
Act which made it illegal to denied the
right to deny anyone the right to vote
based on race or ethnicity so even
though technically women got the right
to vote you could still [ __ ] with them
and so and that's why we want the Equal
Rights Amendment we're technically not
protected under the Constitution I
wonder if Hillary would just pass that
when she gets in a Nixon one of the ER a
to pass before you right wingers get all
buddha at me so um yeah so the 19th
amendment gave voting rights to women
including african-american women in 1920
in 1964 the twenty fourth amendment
outlawed poll taxes removing another
major barrier to african-american voting
in 1965 president lyndon johnson signed
the voting rights act into law so but
here are some other women that we want
to hold in our hearts today and
celebrate other than susan b anthony and
if you want to read this it's actually
on vogue.com you know why not be
fashionable and historical at the same
time Sojourner Truth wrote in 1867 I
feel that I have the right to have just
as much as a man there is a great stir
about colored men getting their rights
but not a word about the colored women
and if colored men get their rights and
colored women not there's the colored
men will be masters over the women and
it will be just as bad as it was before
the abolitionist Sojourner Truth said in
1867 because of the imminent release of
the film suffragettes starring Carey
Mulligan if that movie chronicles the
struggle for the vote in Britain
it also brings to mind our own suffrage
story but though we may have vague
notions of the American women who fought
so heroically for the ballot on this
side of the Atlantic they are in our
minds in our imaginations in the
photographs and first-person narratives
that have come down to us uniformly
white people rendered invisible and so
many accounts black women were in fact
doubly brave fighting a duel oppression
marginalized trivialized humiliated and
dismissed for being both black and
female women like Naomi Anderson assef
rejected asst to give a fiery
controversial speech as my friend Greg
Proops says it's only controversial when
a woman or a black person is saying at
the first women's rights convention in
Chicago in eighteen sixty nine and
Marianne shad carry the second black
female attorney in the country renowned
for her tough oratory who organized the
colored women's progressive franchise
association in eighteen eighty or ana
júlia Cooper who once announced the old
subjective stagnant indolent and
wretched life for women has gone she has
as many resources as men as many
activities beckon her on as large
possibility swell and inspire her heart
end quote or the educator nannie helen
burroughs who asserted when the ballot
is put into the hands of the american
woman the world is going to get a
correct estimate of the negro woman it
will find her a tower of strength of
which poets have never sung orders
orders have never spoken and scholars
have never written or Elizabeth Piper
Endsley who fought for and won full
suffrage for women of all races in
Colorado in eighteen ninety three and
one of sarah massey overton fighting for
the vote in california in the early
years of the 20th century and Francis
Ellen Watkins Harper who had the
presence to state prescients to state I
do not think that the mere extension of
the ballot a panacea for all the ills of
our national life what we need today is
not simply more voters but veter veter
voters Oh God if she had seen them alas
while black women fought and fought hard
many of their Caucasian sisters remained
locked in the racist conventions of the
day when Ida be Wells who founded the
chicago-based alpha suffrage Club
arrived in Washington DC to participate
in the nineteen thirteen suffrage parade
organizers asked the black women if they
would mind very much marching at the
end of the demonstration in 1880 for 71
years before Rosa Parks wouldn't budge
from that bus seat a conductor on the
memphis in charleston railroad ordered
Wells out of the first class lady's car
she sued this time around she attempted
to get the white Illinois delegation to
disavow the parade's enforced
segregation it refused wells in turn
refused to take her place at the back of
the line bystanders on that day more
than a century ago would have seen her
emerge from the crowd and take her place
between two white delegates striding
into history so let us not forget
everybody all right we done with that
now are we done with the election uh I
all right I had a theory um maybe you
shouldn't talk about this well i went i
was just in iowa city this weekend which
is fantastic i love i love Iowa City you
guys it's um you know I don't think I
could live there i don't think there's
enough going on quite for me um but the
people are fantastic it's almost like
like you know you meet smart people who
aren't cynical and shitty like you know
some of your bigger cities smart people
are a little smug about it there's this
just kind of kindness to the iowa city
folks folks and I don't know I felt like
everyone's face wasn't in their phone
the whole time too anyway great show
there at the witching hour festival and
I wasn't able to I was gonna fly in a
night early because I wanted to see
[ __ ] riot speak but I would have had to
get up at four thirty in the morning and
I was just not gonna happen I instead
got up at a more decent hour like seven
and got on a flight got to Iowa City and
the next day went to see the Iggy Pop
documentary gimme danger by Jim Jarmusch
and it was so fantastic I loved it I saw
it in a little movie theater and what
well first of all the guy that announced
it was you know part of the festival and
he was like so we've got so many great
things at this festival you know this
purse
spoke today and now we have this movie
with Iggy Pop that i'm about to show and
then tonight the headliner at the
englert theater is jen kirkman hottie
and silent someone sneeze I was like
what the [ __ ] it was humiliating he
didn't know I was there I just you know
I was slinking in the back and then I
asked the crowd that night had any of
them gone to the documentary and a bunch
of them said they did and I was like why
don't you [ __ ] chair after my name um
but I love the documentary the thise I
thought the thesis statement of the
movie was this in 1973 they've been
influential and touring but but the
Stooges still weren't famous or whatever
and then it kind of didn't address that
it just was sort of a how they got
together and it was very cool and it
apopse a fun guy I think he would be an
icing funner I really do and I just
loved it and then I got introduced to
his Instagram account so if any of you
don't know who I'm talking about at the
end of every I seem fun episode you are
hearing a Stooges song called no fun so
there's something so um download that
song if you're going to get anything
that's that's a great song to help you
get into them but they were fantastic
they were pre punk but they weren't Punk
and they almost were I think he thought
to himself Oh more of a psychedelic kind
of vibe but not corporate and cheesy
like the doors so anyway he has an
instagram account called biggie pop bi g
gy and it's him in his cockatiel biggie
doing music together in his cockatiel
dances and it's the greatest Instagram
account it's all videos and there's only
about 16 of them and it has been making
me happy for the past few days but I had
a theory are there any and I mean famous
like selling out arenas and have their
own show are there any famous female
comics that were Punk's growing up in
other words did I by not listening to
the commercially viable music growing up
and I think high-fidelity the movie asks
this question did the music you were
listening to growing up speak to you
because you already were that way or did
it change you that's not quite how they
said in high fidelity but I got the
message is which comes first you're a
relation or do you get molded so
did I get molded into an aesthetic of
do-it-yourself small crowds you're great
but only a few people like you like I
didn't mean to do that per se I had big
non punk rock dreams for myself and then
I realized God did I listened to so much
I mean you think about music three four
five six hours a day at least I mean I
listen to music as a teenager in my
headphones in between classes at school
during at least one lunch hour walking
to and from school at least 20 minutes
in my room all night 3-4 hours I mean
that's a lot of music all day long and
it just constantly the punk messages of
like you know everything popular sucks
in all this and so I feel like I never
learned to play a certain game or be a
certain type of person and I wonder I'm
just putting it out there do people who
listen to pie I would like to save it
find anyone everyone famous and I'm
gonna sing comics only stand-up comics
only because I feel like you can get a
punk rock ethos through in a screenplay
or something but stand-up comics you
just have to stand there and be
themselves in front of people if who you
are is sort of a fringe loving music
person are you going to appeal to
everybody like just in a vibe just in a
cosmic sense I would love to list like
the 20 most successful stand-ups maybe
not of all time because you have to
understand punk was going on during some
of the most famous comics so to get into
older punk that of bands that have
broken up when you're a teenager in the
90s is a certain type of person that
doesn't really go with the mainstream so
if you're let's say from the 90s on the
25 to 30 most famous successful
financially earning stand-up comedians
how many of the metal punk rock
background in in terms of what they
listen to you I bet it's only ten
percent if someone actually does at
research I would love it i'd love to be
wrong because i I've given up I've given
up on ever having a large audience and I
really just want one imagine you had if
I had 20,000 people in each city to come
see me and I charge you guys what a
hundred dollars a ticket I could make
you
two million dollars a show what do three
shows a year so I don't think I'm gonna
get there is what I'm saying and I do I
blame listening to the sex pistols for
that so well she yes I didn't even get
I've already talked about everything I
feel like we're gonna have to go back
who I was gonna talk about driverless
cars but oh this is a fun article so I
forgot that I had all this other papers
here that was gross sorry for that so
door close buttons on elevators and
pressing crosswalk buttons is from the
new york times do not work there just
put there to give you a sense of control
and so this is what the article says
okay some buttons we regularly rely on
to get results are mere artifice
placebos that promote an illusion of
control but then reality do not work no
matter how long or how hard you press it
will not change the outcome be prepared
to be surprised and disappointed by some
of these examples do our close buttons
on elevators karen w penafiel executive
director of national elevator industry
Inc national elevator industry and how
can I help you this is Karen yes well
what were ya what we're working on right
now is a button that doesn't work it's
one of the most important features on an
elevator we're good to safety later but
I think it's more important instead of
those pulleys that keep it in the air
will have someone look at those in 10
years but right now I'm really focused
on this new button anyway said the
closed door feature faded into
obsolescence a few years after the
enactment of the Americans with
Disabilities Act in 1990 the legislation
required that elevator doors remain open
long enough for anyone who uses crutches
a cane or a wheelchair to get on board
said mrs. penafiel in an interview on
Tuesday quote the riding public would
not be able to make those doors close
any faster ah ok so that's actually kind
of a good thing like the doors don't
shut that quickly because we've got our
friends and families who are in
wheelchairs using crutches or a cane or
maybe just someone walk slow so you
can't actually make it close faster so
you
Bowie's there in an elevator who see
something wheelchair want to close it
but what if you're being chased by a
murderer oh do you know I think about
this all the [ __ ] time right well at
that point I mean yeah I think about
this all the time when the elevator when
I'm in the elevator and I'm like hitting
the door button I always think what if
someone crazy was coming I'm [ __ ] yeah
well I feel like maybe we should add
that in like the the Americans with
Disabilities Act and people who might be
being chased by a murderer so we can
have elevators that if you hit the
button the door does close yeah and we
would have to trust ourselves as people
that we would not use it to close the
door and a handicapped person no no if
you hit it like like like with with your
do not disturb on your phone like if
someone calls three times in a row in
less than two minutes or something it
will ring like it should be like that
for the button like I don't know that
yeah yeah um so if you hit it like yeah
30 times in a minute I'm just gonna say
three times over three times yeah I'm
exaggerated but wait so I don't know
this so if i have my do not disturb on
which I don't put on in case someone
dies if they call me three times it
rings yeah that's [ __ ] frightening so
then you know knows it's an emergency
but then you know when the phone rings
it it's probably one unless some idiot
friend yrs keeps calling yeah but then
seeing them people like my parents they
might not know this they were just call
once and be like well I guess I'll just
die on the floor but that's their
problem I may I'll just have to tell
them yeah um that's really that's good
okay yes so now the buttons can be
operated by firefighters and maintenance
worker who have the proper keys or codes
well obviously crosswalk signals New
Yorkers those who don't jaywalk which is
no one have four years dutifully
followed the instructions on the metal
signs to cross street push button wait
for walk signal but his new york times
reported in 2004 the city deactivated
most of the pedestrian buttons along ago
with the emergence of computer
controlled traffic signals I guess I
never thought of them as not computer
controlled more than 25 to 35 hundred
walk buttons that were in place existed
his mechanical placebos about 500 were
removed during major construction it was
it would cost a million
dismantle the non-functioning mechanism
so city officials decided to keep them
in place not really I feel like office
thermostats what same problem that
confronts couples at home one person's
perception than a room is too cold as
and others that it's too warm faces
offers workers as well depending on
where you work you might find the
thermostat in a plastic case under lock
and key but if you're lucky you might
have control over one will you think you
have control the air conditioning
heating and refrigeration news it's my
favourite newspaper I got all my
election news from the air conditioning
heating and refrigeration News reported
in 2003 that asked readers in an
informal online survey whether they had
ever installed dummy thermostats of 70
who responded 50 ones that they had
david trimble of Fort Collins Colorado
wrote the news that people felt better
that they could control the temperature
in their work this cut down the number
of servers calls by over seventy five
percent that's a good point although i
have read that offices are technically
sexist because people make fun of women
who are too cold but our body
temperatures are sometimes lower than
men's because we're inferior um and
we're cold [ __ ] um sense of control I
don't know what this button is anymore
okay so yeah elevator thermos up
crosswalk it's all [ __ ] you guys I
have listened or emails that I don't
want to read oh because I already read
one of them I mean I don't know all
right here look it I did something last
week do you remember my episode
everybody where I interviewed my friend
Dan it was a days seem fun and we were
talking about when you think of super
famous people girl like did they do this
like this glint of paltrow know what
getting her parking ticket validated is
like I don't think so and so two weeks
ago I went and sold my computer an ipad
i had in an ipod and I felt I mean I
wanted to recycle them you know mike has
thrown in the trash but I had no one to
give them to and like personally that I
knew and I was like well there is a
place in my neighborhood that gives you
money for it
I think I got 300 bucks for all three
total and they were like sorry you know
this computer's a little broken and i
was like i don't care i just want to not
have them sitting around anymore and if
i can get 300 bucks for it great and
then I thought is that like am i keeping
it real or am i and I couldn't someone I
wanted that money I mean I thought that
was good for me but I don't how god I
guess what a successful person do that I
mean maybe their assistant would go do
it for them but would they even think of
that where they just be like take it to
a recycling place I don't know I just
felt like this is definitely something
else a mariah carey is not standing in
line at a place to sell her laptop I
felt sort of like I was at a pawn shop I
felt trashy but there's nothing trashy
about recycling for cash I mean I think
it's great but I went in and it was a it
seemed like an israeli guy running it
i'm not exactly sure how to pinpoint the
ethnicity but i believe he was Jewish it
was also a that had a temples name on it
like you know those paper counters you
get that I can't believe people still
use it was like blah blah blah temple
and when he went through my old computer
my iCloud was on so suddenly emails that
I had recently came up and my boyfriend
Jake who is Jewish had for some reason
just it was like in relation to
something we were texting about but it
was like funny and uh he just wrote me
an email that said I am Jewish and it
was it seems anti-semitic when this
shiksa girl comes in were there little
German faith you know and gives the
laptop to the guy and then he just the
iCloud opens and this email it was like
there wasn't that he was looking through
my emails but it was like it showed up
on the home screen sort of his like a an
alert and it just said friend didn't say
his last name so he couldn't even see
that was it kind of a Jewish sending
less and he just said Jake I am Jewish
and it sounded sarcastic like someone
was making fun of our Jewish
neighbors and that email stayed stuck
like that for 10 minutes so the whole
time this guy is helping me and it I'm
just trying to sell my laptop that says
I am Jewish and I felt like a [ __ ]
idiot and I'm like do I address this or
do I look more paranoid if I'm like no
that's no and so I just didn't say
anything and I'm just wondering and then
I was telling someone I do this and
they're like do you stay there where
they clear it I go no you turn off your
iCloud and then you give it to them and
they clear it and they're like what if
they didn't I'm like what are they gonna
find emails to myself about here's an
article to read on I seem fun I mean I'm
not running for president um I don't
know it's like what what are they gonna
find again I have one nude photo of
myself that if it went viral I'd be so
happy I'd never I had it was perfection
and I didn't take it for a man I took it
for myself to monitor I was trying to
see what I would look like without
clothes on uh I was actually just me
what I'd look like a new bathing suit
before I went on this thing from for
some reason i justed without my clothes
on anyway you can't really see the
hoo-ha you can just see them everything
else but uh felt real good about the
shape my body was in that picture and
again i welcome you to hack my computer
and pass it around anyway so there's
that um Oh God okay I'm gonna say Iowa
City you have one annoying person in
there so I was in a Starbucks don't do
mom and pop that starbucks was boomin
was like a nightclub it was just
constant lying going around and everyone
was in that starbucks there really
wasn't that many mom-and-pop coffee
shops that I saw unless you want
something from like a gross pot of
coffee I'm gonna get so many emails that
I'm there is one I had some writing to
do i'm working on a couple scripts that
no one's asking me to buy my true cell
and I'm enjoying it I'm enjoying using a
different part of my brain I haven't
been on the road walks up for last
weekend but I will be off the road for a
little while six months to a year and I
am enjoying using the other part of my
brain which is script writing and all
that kind of stuff and comin up pitching
TV shows I've been doing a little
of that and I like using that part my
brain I don't have anything to say right
now and stand up so anyway I like to
work in starbucks because the Wi-Fi is
reliable and when i'm writing i often
use Wi-Fi to look up things that i need
to solidify so and I trust the coffee I
know what it's going to taste like and I
am cleared to drink decaf by my vocal
coach therapist dr. so I like to get my
decaf americano because I don't think
decaf tastes that well when you get it
anywhere else and I can't tell the
difference between decaf and regular
americano at starbucks except for I
don't get a jolt right but I was on
sudafed so I was plenty speedy so anyway
I'm writing typey typey typey oh my god
it's so brilliant you can't believe it
and this guy is standing next to me
probably like 18 and he's talking to his
friend and he's like nope this is like
two dudes and one of them is totally the
aww technically guys like John
technically you're not getting a you're
not getting a cappuccino you're getting
a milkshake is like if it has sugar and
flavoring and milk in it that's a
milkshake don't call it coffee his
friends like I'm just taught the name of
it is Frappuccino so I'm just getting
that it was like that's not coffee or
cappuccino site but it's not a
cappuccino I was a shut up and it was
like this guy thought he was the first
one to say it's like honey starbucks
been around for decades like congrats on
your little you know Bill Hicks routine
you're working on but its buying in the
old lady next to you ah just call it a
milkshake what are you even in there for
like your friend go in and buy something
and you shut up god I would don't you
wish you could but into conversations
that point and go your friend sucks dude
you like hang out by yourself or come
sit with me i'm not going to talk to you
but it was do you need shelter from this
[ __ ] blowhard so anyway what nothing
really happened on the plane this time
around um i flew from LAX to atlanta
lots of people and Trump t-shirts at the
atlanta airport getting on my flight
from atlanta to iowa so i don't know if
they were going canvassing or what they
were doing but it was interesting you
know when you see people in person and
let me make a plea is my letter to
America this is why I actually liked
in comedy because I don't hate people
who support Trump I truly believe that
everybody is secretly a liberal but they
don't know it everyone want like I
believe this everyone wants jobs coming
back to America I do everybody wants a
thriving infrastructure so we don't have
bridges falling down and we have the
most up-to-date trains high-speed rail I
do I think everyone wants health care
for all I know that sounds controversial
I think it's because people have been
tricked into thinking its socialist
which is bad but Medicare as it exists
currently a socialist and what every
congressional Congress and house person
senator has is sort of single-payer
health care they have they are fully
covered with our tax dollars so I want
everyone to have health care that's
covered by our tax dollars anyone you
think well my taxes will go up I'm not
sure the details of that but you will
save money because there's no way that
you pay more in taxes than you do for
your health care whether it's your
deductible or that's not covered or you
had an operation there's no [ __ ] way
so anyway I think that's what we want
right I think people want to write to
their guns I'm not loving guns but you
know I'm not trying take them away
people want you know some people don't
want a woman have the right to choose
but that is technically already legal
it's already in the Constitution so we
don't even have to keep arguing about it
I think people want great education
great public schools so we don't have to
just privatize you know so the richest
people aren't the only ones getting a
good education and then go with the auto
industry saved I think we probably want
less war I think we understand that our
kids and friends and relatives and
ourselves are dying in wars that other
people start I think we want less
dependence on foreign oil I think we
want to help the environment well maybe
you don't believe in global warming but
it but is it such a belief for you that
you want to stop people from finding
alternate ways to not pollute I mean I
don't think so so I think the two issues
that people really might actually not
agree on as a woman's right to choose an
environment but again if progress
marched on without you on that one I
think you would be okay I think you
would see it doesn't affect your life
that much and actually in ways you don't
understand women having a right to
choose does affect your life because we
have less people growing up in poverty
with children they're being forced to
take care okay what so whenever I see a
trump supporter or an overly liberal
person who's like gentle sign only I
just go oh we all want the same stuff
basically and they're probably really
nice people because I have Trump
supporters in my family and they're so
nice and I love them and they're they're
not bad people and you know they may be
racist in general which is inexcusable
at this point but one on one they would
not be if they actually had people in
their life that were different religions
different colors different genders
different gender identity different
whatever romantic sexual orientation
whatever but when I actually just see
people in person I just my heart melts
them I'm like oh we're all just fun I
mean once you get on a plane and it
takes off you have zero control and
you're on the same boat so and when I do
comedy for people in everyone laughs I
don't know who's voting for whom and it
just it just makes me feel good that
there are these tiny moments whether
it's we're all laughing at the same joke
or we're on the same plane that again we
have no control over if I can just find
those tiny moments where are all one I
feel a little more calm because I know
at the heart of it it's just people who
and I don't I guess I'm condescending by
saying they're getting it wrong but I
truly believe they are but I I I don't
hate I really don't and I feel hatred
directed at me for the candidate that I
want and that really makes me feel sad I
hate Trump I don't hate Trump supporters
and so anyway I really hope that it was
my point on how to point o getting on
the plane seeing the Trump supporters so
I don't know really what where I want to
go with that statement but there is just
something I feel very lucky to get to do
what I do because I get a chance so
often to not just see people as a group
even though weirdly I see you as a group
in my
audience on stage but I understand that
it's made up of so many different kinds
of people and I think it's lovely but
when I watch on TV people chanting lock
her up and you know it scares me it
scares me and I and I don't like how it
sounds and I really hope that tonight
there's a sense of you know we all have
to come together under the president we
don't have to i mean but we just can't
be violent and I uh I I don't know I
just want to be able to feel celebratory
and I don't want anyone to ruin it for
me and I won't let them but I was my
point of oso I'm on the plane and I'm
a-gettin like angsty when I see I'm in
Atlanta and I see all these Trumpy guys
and they make me feel nervous I don't
like it and then I see them getting on
my plane and it just equalized and
humanized us all like we're all just
walking to this tin thing that flies
away and we hope it works out and so
that i started my heart started melting
like the grinch know his heart didn't
melt it grew three sizes but you know
what I'm saying or like a winter warlock
it and you get what I'm saying a
Christmas movie so I'm sitting on the
plane and I got this like burst of good
mood it was very bizarre was like
someone had given me a dopamine pill
like a good mood endorphins a serotonin
booster and seeing that love can do you
don't need all those myths so this woman
gets on a plane and she's standing next
to me know I'm in the first row of
Economy Comfort no big deal and this
woman is next to me and she's in a long
line so she's gonna be standing next to
me for at least five minutes I'm here
Wow oh and I'm like oh my god there's a
cat I love cats I'm so excited and I
look and she's got a keg oh oh do you
have a cat she was like sorry sorry I
know it's loud I'm like no I love it
what's your kitty and I looking as a
black-and-white tuxedo kidding my
favorite kind of giddy and it was just
like wow and she was like his name is
Georgie we're moving back to you know we
just moved from Georgia
or something and she was like you know
he's really scared but he's been with me
my whole life he's 15 and I was like oh
my god and I really really was like I
hope he's ok I hope your I really like
wanted to go to the person sitting next
to her and go I have a way better seat
in Economy Comfort right on the aisle if
I can sow sit in a [ __ ] middle seat
can I sit next to this black and white
cat and I was like do I want to jump to
the level of being that person who's
like I'm gonna um give up my seat and go
sit next to a woman who didn't ask by
the way she probably doesn't want to be
spoken to on the flight she's anything
like me she's got her own agenda but I
wanted to sit and help her with the cat
like how could I be helpful they can't
might not want anything to do with me i
love that I think that I'm a cat
whisperer the most difficult animal to
get on your side but i just thought i
might sit next to it and give him like
head rubs or something but I didn't do
it don't just calm down i haven't
changed that much but that's where the
love the love of my fellow man and woman
was sending me as I was talking to
people about their cats and I could see
the women sitting next to me were like
oh boy I think they were nervous if we
got a talker on our hands and I was like
don't worry I'll shut the [ __ ] up right
quick and then I watched a movie what
did I watch all was great I'm no on the
flight from LA to Atlanta Delta had iris
the hours apfel documentary devil wears
prada had sex in the city one end to the
movie I wanted to watch the second Sex
in the City movie so badly I've seen it
50 times and I know it's got its
problems but it's so ridiculous that I
kind of love it and I was like I don't
have the balls to watch this I am NOT
people are as like you don't give a [ __ ]
I do actually I give a [ __ ] sometimes I
could not watch that movie on the plane
I just felt like people would think I
was dumb so he didn't I did actually
mainly just work on the plane but I like
having something in my headphones and
did something I can look up at so I put
on the iris apfel documentary which I've
already seen but if you guys haven't
it's great and if you're like man Ewing
it in it's made by the maze Leigh
brothers who did
a Grey Gardens so it's like you know
smarty pants directors documentarians
we're now dead um anyway iris is alive
it's a great documentary if you want to
take your mind up the election it's
fantastic watch it iris apfel AP fe l is
her last name and the documentary is
just called iris and it's great but a 95
year old fashionista woman in New York
and she and her husband had a [ __ ]
rich life in a red kids by the way and
they just went around the world and
procured and curated of fabrics and
stuff and they used to decorate for like
the White House and other famous people
and just like to really cool meant for
each other old people hanging out in
their manhattan apartment she keeps her
Christmas decorations up year-round I
mean oh my god might react I gotta get a
home in my tree I'm so [ __ ] excited
about this thing being up there's gonna
be 98 in 280 degrees in Los Angeles this
week and next and I don't think it is
global warming because when I first
moved here in 2001 in november i was
wearing a winter coat and not because he
a bloody thing you had [ __ ] bat bat bat
bat it was like 45 degrees it was chilly
it would get cold it would be 65 in the
day and about like 45 minute the Sun
went down and so nowadays it's 95 during
the day and 75 at night and it's [ __ ]
out of your air conditioning on November
I gotta move to New York I gotta move I
need this podcast to get a million
listeners and then the advertising will
go through the roof and I'll make enough
to buy my Tribeca apartment that I want
although maybe I live more near central
park so I could be closer to some trees
because i think i would eventually get
sick of not being around nature not that
i am now but i like a tree or two is
nice so yeah i gotta move back to New
York i [ __ ] miss it and I I just
don't like her lay anymore I think Elly
is cool like it's listen you're gonna
live in any two cities I I don't know
don't listen to me i'm a [ __ ] snob
anyway uh that's it i talked about
computer I
want to meet your article about
driverless cars i'll read it next week
or we'll discuss it how about this when
you send me an email to I seem fun at
gmail com and tell me if you would you
know like if money was no object would
you get a driverless car right now and
then if not it or you could answer the
question of are you excited do you think
it's better for the world or America or
whatever to have like if every car was
driverless would you like that do you
like driving or do you would you rather
be like a passenger in your own car so
you could do other stuff email me that I
seem fun @ gmail.con just put driverless
car in the subject heading and then next
week when I read the article I'll have
you that way you guys will be able to
weigh in in real time isn't this fun I
haven't checked the listener email and
so long and it's time for us to sign off
in about four minutes so what I'm going
to do is just log into the listener
email right now my password was changed
23 days ago uh-oh what row as they say
if I don't have the right password I
don't remember changing it and got
uneven [ __ ] drink like to work on
these black holes or I don't remember
anything I mean I drink but not like
once a month I have all glass of what
okay um nowhere is it gmail I seem fun
at gmail where is it I pee paw paw paw
uh I seem fun here it is okay let's see
let's see if this password works wrong
password try again what have I done nope
I don't remember my password uh it says
didn't change your password I mean I
don't think I did but I must've wait
it's just letting me choose it right now
that's weird okay
hang on one sec I'm changing it right
now yeah that's right that's what you
can get on the I seem fun podcast is
someone changing their password in real
time I'm now signed in this seems so
weird that I could just change it ok um
ok dear Jen this is a compliment email
who gives a [ __ ] I'm complimenting
myself the subject heading is thank you
for validating me though you don't know
you did oh I love it already dear Jen I
am a girl I am a girl who never stays in
the same place for longer than a few
months at a time this lifestyle led me
to a midnight train from bras off to
cluj napoca Transylvania I sorry about
that pronunciation with no one who spoke
English or German but an anti-semitic
troubadour if I wanted to have a
conversation it had to be with this
violinist who told me he knew I was a
Jew and that the Jews have suffered so
much because they didn't accept Jesus I
was this dovetails nicely into my story
about the selling the computer I began
to fear for my life I got off the train
at the wrong stop and ended up in the
middle of nowhere I lived but I was
scared now everyone tells me i'm stupid
for having been there in the first place
cut to the first of october i found
myself sitting in the second row at your
Netflix special taping when you started
talking about your solo trip to Italy
and all this strife you took for solo
traveling as a woman and later when you
talked about street harassment I felt so
good I saw that you one of my heroes are
like me you have the kind of life I
strive for and you got it from saying
yes to life and not doing what girls are
supposed to do I love your book in your
podcast I swear to go to every one of
your shows I can alex the kidd see more
alright thank you Alex what listen me
don't look up to my life too much
because it's a lot of work touring this
year took its toll on me and
it was a lot more work for what I had
intended to put into things and so it
took away from a lot of areas in my life
so I didn't live a very well-rounded
life this year and I'd like to fix that
and so that's why I'm taking some time
off but I guess you're right in general
I kind of do what I want when I want
within reason I have never been to bras
off or Transylvania and I think
traveling for fun is really cool and
something if you can financially get it
done do it I actually don't travel for
fun too much and so I'd like to do more
of that myself so look up to yourself
not me because you already had done this
and you know yeah it's uh it's you
weren't stupid to do that I mean you
didn't know that you were going to run
into an anti-semitic violinist and
people can be awful and scary and try to
murder you anywhere you go you can walk
outside your house and something bad
could happen at the local coffee shop so
why not travel take a risk and I'm glad
I validated you you felt validated so
that's great okay I guess that's it I'm
read I've got a lot of emails oh boy oh
boy hang on one more no nevermind okay
that's it well this is how every episode
ends I start wandering and I get a DD
and it's perfect i am going to drive
home now and begin putting up my
christmas tree until next week which
will not be a live video podcast Oh next
week's episode I'm so many people keep
asking me how I got over my fear of
flying and I find it I was getting
frustrated because it's like god I talk
about this all the time on the podcast
have talked about at my books and I'm
like you know what I'm just going to
make an entire episode called fear of
flying and so next week's episode is
going to be from every angle from
medication to books I read to
meditations to psychiatric advice to
just life experience how I got over my
fear of flying and it will be a full
hour and it will take it apart from
every angle and you can pick which angle
might work best for you and your fear
and I'm really excited to do it I'm like
putting a lot of work into it right now
in terms of outlining exactly what I
want to talk about because I really
wanted to help people and that way when
people ask me how I can send them a link
to that episode so I hope you find that
interesting I think it'll be really cool
and then of course coming up this Friday
night is the third episode of this week
seemed fun where I talk about pop
culture and politics news that meant
something to me this week not
necessarily the world at large okay so
until this week seemed fun or next week
have fun